Do you ever use one of those
teeter inversion tables? Um,
now I just got something free from
you guys that were in the lobby.
What's that thing called? Pro formas
or whatever. Oh, that's a so, right.
That's a so a, so OSC massager.
Isn't that great? So, uh,
that's this muscle in here.
I'm going to come on that thing and thing.
Feels fucking good brother.
Sorry.
Room and thinking feels good
that you are so horny today.
I had to dry. It's like 20 minute drive
over right here. Oh, that kitchen morning.
Get Ivan. Nothing like driving
dude note. I'll say this.
Things that get me a rec these
days, driving, being on planes.
You know that uh,
bumpy roads
doing those bumpy roads.
Boners I, there's a real,
you asked me one time
ever they had a lady, uh,
I felt like I got an erection on a
plane and she got pissed. She told the,
she told the flight attendant to get me
a blanket. Well, did you have it out?
No,
I was asleep and it was in my pants.
It was in your pants and
she saw it somehow. Yeah,
she saw my pants cause I wear lean pants,
lean pants or you know,
I wasn't wearing like a like a fat suit
canvas or anything, you know, textiles
that
that's crazy that she's
looking over at your race.
But I guess if I was a woman and
a dude had a rock hard boner,
just like a couple of fee, I would know.
That's like a ticking time bomb. Like hey,
all right, but I'm on a plane, I'm going
home. Yeah, but what if you're a pervert?
Yeah, I am a pervert but I'm still
just going home and not using my dick.
What kind of scale of
a pervert are you have?
Like 10 is jerking off in front of people
on the subway with a knock that I have
a friend that's a flasher though.
Well you this flashes and it flashes a
jerk off on people. He doesn't do that.
That's 10 and then nine is a flasher that
just pretends to jerk off in front of
you. It doesn't finish.
Yeah or can't get hard.
And then you've got to go back from there.
Seven a softball five.
What do you look at? Three? No October
perverted tendencies like would, I guess
it's like what is perverted, you know?
Well it goes back to the porn talk.
Like you said that you had a problem with
porn, you were watching too much porn.
It became a habit for me. That's
what I didn't like. It became a,
instead of me wanting to
watch pornography became, oh,
I'm used to watching pornography at night,
so I'm going to do it right.
Jerk Golf and get a little bit of rest.
I didn't like the habit,
but it created a bad habit.
Well you, uh, you get real,
uh,
intense thinking about things.
Even when we're talking
about like business stuff.
Like you can tell like you get,
you focus on things, which is good.
If it's a good thing,
you know,
but sometimes that kind of thinking
can get away from you. Yeah.
I think it does sometimes for now the
same kind of focus that can get you really
excited about something that's productive
in your life can also get you obsessed
with something that's not productive.
So Sec, the kind of person that you are.
And a lot of performers. You're an
impulsive, creative person. Impulsive,
creative. People sometimes
get cotton ruts, you know,
and there's a bunch of different
reasons I think for for addictions.
I think their psychological
addictions is physical addictions.
Some of them are undeniable, like physical
addictions. Some of them will kill you.
Like you get off of alcohol
too quick, you'll die. Yeah.
It's a physical addiction that is real.
I can't point.
You can't pretend it's not real.
That shit will kill you. Right.
So it's obviously real.
But then there's other ones like
washing your hands too many times,
like some people are addicted to
washing their hands. I know I do it.
It doesn't go anywhere without
Purell everywhere. Washing his hands,
he's putting Praill. It's crazy. She's
hand is linked to touch door knobs,
put touches, door Knob, Purell back to
the hands. It's weird. And you, you,
you fuck up your skin flora,
like it's not good. Yeah.
We had a dude that used to
lick both of his shoulders for,
he'd start talking to me. Oh, that's
good. That's good. It's crazy.
That's a let motherfuckers know you're
serious. Oh yeah. That's an Irish.
Hello. Right. Well, we'll
wait. Where were in crazy town?
You're the mayor.
Lucky doing you lick your shoulders a tea.
We had to do it in our town.
He put like a chocolate on your shoulder
and you try to get it off the heat.
It all. That's not right.
That guy's is going to grab
you one damn. Fuck you. Well,
he did get in trouble for
something. I don't remember
what it was. I, I'd grown up,
but he was, he's like one of those
angler fish. He's tricking you. Yeah.
He's getting you to look at that.
Huh?
It's going to get you come
looking for that chocolate. God,
he did off my shoulder, my
shoulder. Boom. He looked down.
He's got a bat in his hands. Well, if
you said it's like you on that play,
get your chocolate. Come get
you shot. Just chocolate.